- Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Pankaj Kumar.
I lead at AWS practice for
energy and few other markets.
And with me we have a very special client
who keep Las Vegas warm.
Please welcome Laxman from Southwest Gas.
- Thank you.
- And Kalyan.
So today we are gonna talk
about a very different subject.
Like, I know there's a
lot being talked about,
cool agentic AI applications
and how it's, you know,
being applied to business.
What we are gonna talk about
is the readiness for agentic AI.
We heard in the morning
there is a lot of boring work
that goes behind being ready.
So we are gonna talk a little bit on that.
This is the agenda that we'll cover.
So we'll start with the
introduction to Southwest Gas.
Laxman.
- Thank you Pankaj.
Good afternoon everyone,
welcome to Las Vegas.
We are Southwest Gas.
We are based out of Las Vegas,
headquarters in Las Vegas,
and we serve three states,
Arizona, California, and Nevada.
We serve around 2.3 million customers
across three different states.
We are,
from customer experience perspective,
we won five years in a row,
number one customer satisfaction
J.D. Awards in west large
customer and residential category.
And also we won recently
two SAP innovation awards
for our digital transformation
on SAP RISE and BTP innovations.
- So I think a lot being talked about
how these agentic AI projects are failing.
If you have read the MID report,
it says almost 95% of the organization
report seeing zero outcome.
A lot of POCs going on, but
not a lot of production.
You know, quality
upgrade that is going on.
Gartner has said almost 40%
of the agentic AI projects
will be canceled by 2027.
So these are scary numbers.
HFS research says that
what, and why is all done
it's it's about how of AI
which will define 2026.
Now let's step back and think about
why these people are
forecasting such failures.
We at IBM value research,
IBM has done our own research
talking to multiple clients
across geographies and across businesses.
One of the key things that we note
is that agentic AI demands
a new operating model,
which is engineered from bottoms up.
So if you look at that diagram
where we talk about, on the top,
scalable, flexible, and secure
hybrid cloud infrastructure is the key.
And then you look at the left,
which is around enterprise applications,
ecosystem partner systems,
and external data sources,
which need to be interconnected.
If you take one thing out of the session,
remember, interconnected workflows.
So it need to be, as we work,
people and agents work in harmony,
I think is very critical for us
to have interconnected
workflows all across.
So this goes back to the
theme of our topic here,
which is around readiness for agentic AI.
Not just being cool AI,
but how do we do that boring
work on infrastructure,
governance, security, cloud, to be ready.
As Laxman pointed out,
Southwest Gas has been
winning a number of awards.
That's for a reason,
because they are highly innovative,
they think very carefully,
but also move with with velocity, right.
So it's great to learn from them
how they are embarking on their journey.
And IBM and AWS have a small role to play
in their journey to agentic AI.
With that, I'll hand it over to Kalyan
to talk about some of
the business challenges
they were experiencing
when they were on-prem
and how it was hindering their innovation.
- Thank you, Pankaj.
Thanks everyone for joining us today.
Yeah, I will walk you through
our business challenges
when we were on on-prem.
Yeah, our on-prem infrastructure
was aged infrastructure
and the most challenges
were like, you know,
maintaining those servers, right.
So we had to spend a lot on
maintaining those systems
and upgrading those servers.
And also the scalability.
So we couldn't able to extend
according to our business demand.
So it's restricting our support for demand
and also the security
and compliance complexity
where our team needs to
manually update the patches
to avoid security vulnerabilities.
And also, I would like to hold a bit here,
lack of ability to do agentic AI.
I would like to relate to my personal case
where few months ago I thought
of teaching AI to my kids,
their too young, but you know,
to do some fun AI stuff,
videos and all stuff.
But my old laptop was not supporting to,
you know, do those innovative stuff.
Similarly, when you
compare to the broader way
a company having aged infrastructure,
then you need a platform, strong platform,
a future ready digital core platform
where you can explore more innovations.
That's what we did from the Southwest Gas.
And thanks to our leadership
for taking this innovative step forward
and implementing SAP
RISE on AWS altogether.
And we are ready to start
our innovation journey.
And we already did couple
of use cases on agentic AI
and I'd like Laxman to talk
about our SAP RISE journey.
Thank you.
- So if you see here, oops, sorry.
So we actually, as a part
of our cloud first journey
and also exiting our
on-prem infrastructure,
we moved the first SAP
mission critical system
to AWS running on SAP on RISE this year.
We were able to move everything
that we have in our SAP landscape
and simplify the architecture,
and also integrations
from going from PO to
BTP integration suite.
We have done everything in four months.
That's why we won Fast and
Furious Cloud ERP migration
in SAP Utilities this year.
So how we are able to do that?
It's because, you know, the
partnership that we have
with SAP, IBM, and AWS.
IBM is our strategic partner.
IBM is the global partner for SAP
as well as AWS.
We use IBM's, you know,
strategic partnership
to ensure the speed and
the timelines that we need
is aligned with the project timelines.
So this is one of the key
partnership I want to highlight.
Having IBM supporting us on the,
you know, not just SAP,
we also started going our on-prem systems,
like rest of the systems
which are running on Oracle,
70% of the workload
going to the AWS cloud infrastructure,
So this is allowing us to prepare
for next generation of digital adoption.
As Southwest, we are growing organically.
We are adding 40,000 customers
in our business territory every year.
And our business
requirements are changing,
our customer demands are increasing
and also we actually take
pride in serving our customers
and make them easy in order to,
you know, how they interact with us.
We are the number one mobile app
powered by SCW in North America
with 86,000 5 star reviews in Apple Store.
I believe there is no other
company has this many reviews,
even in the global level
for 2.3 million customers.
So we take very seriously
when we do these loss
transformation projects
and, you know, keeping in, ensuring that,
how we are going to serve
these customers better
with the infrastructure that
we are going to get into.
We see already tremendous improvements
with our SAP RISE running
on AWS just migrating it.
We will cover in some other slides.
So again,
performance is increased by 35%
just going from our world
on-prem hardware gear
to AWS latest and greatest infrastructure,
We didn't tune anything,
it's just a migration.
It's actually, you know,
the cloud computing power of AWS
allowed us to run faster.
We used to run mission critical jobs,
which is called meter to cash
every night from six all
the way to two o'clock,
which is very important for us.
Now after going to SAP RISE,
we are actually completing
that within midnight.
So that allows our
resources to sleep early
and also ensuring that we
bill our customers every day
without any issues.
And also this is helping us to,
we are able to capitalize
with the help of IBM.
IBM was able to provide us
the language that we need,
work with our accounting,
and working with our partners
to allow us to capitalize.
This is very important aspect for us
when it comes to capitalization.
And also the resources that are supporting
on the on-prem that they are now focusing
on learning more AWS cloud operations
and doing more optimizations, automations,
so that they don't have to do
the same level of jobs that they're doing.
Our goal is try to move away from,
keep the lights on hours
to innovate faster.
This is really helping us
with moving the responsibilities
of managing by customer
to managing by SAP and AWS
helping us to innovate much faster.
- Thank you, Laxman.
So I'll be talking about AI use cases
that are already in implementation phase.
So our company Southwest Gas embrace AI
and when we approach
customer agents and you know,
when we ask about what are the pain areas,
they said this were some of the questions
they were unable to answer
quickly to the customers.
That's when we thought
of building an agentic AI
for smart gas bill analyzer,
where most of the customers
used to ask why my bill is high.
So they don't just consider
about some root cause
analysis or whatever.
It used to take currently over 15 minutes,
10 to 15 minutes, and it could lead to,
you know, frustration,
right, for the customers.
So what are the challenges that, you know,
currently our agents are facing?
So how this AI could help
and what all the business value that,
you know, it can gain customer trust
and you know, it can fewer our disputes
and can reduce the call volume.
I would like to go through
the root cause analysis
that we found for this, you know,
to build this agentic AI case.
So there are three categories.
One is customer related reasons.
That could be behavioral changes
while using these
appliances and, you know,
making, you know, more consumption.
One could be, and also
inefficient appliances
like, you know, maybe customers
are using some degrading systems,
HVAC systems or, you know, water heaters.
And also some behavioral changes.
Maybe some of the
customers could, you know,
keep the appliance uses
for a longer period
and everything resides in a system, right?
So what our agentic AI can does, you know,
we extracts the data from the
systems that mentioned there
from MDMS and billing systems
and also from S4 and
customer support portal.
And it can reason, it can extract the data
and fine tune and validate
and provide the actual reason
and give an insightful summary
to the customer agents.
So the second category is, like,
due to some faulty technical reasons
like faulty machines,
equipment like, you know.
Maybe sometimes the
smart devices won't work
or you know, the meter
may be faulty meters there
and you know, due to some
longer billing cycles, right.
That could be also a reason.
And additional tariffs
or rate plan changes,
that could also lead
to increase the bills.
And we cannot deny the
fact that, you know,
even the external factors
like weather, right.
So mostly in the cold weather
customers switch on their heaters.
That could also increase
their bills, gas bills.
And also the rate changes
and sometimes our regulatory
surcharges as well,
because of that also it could lead.
And during the outages some customers felt
even my bill is high
even though some of the outages happen.
But that can be, you know,
due to some of the compensations
planned afterwards.
So all the data can be extracted
from the relevant systems
and then feed to our agentic AI
and what agentic AI can
intelligently validate
and provide a proper reasoning
to our call center agents.
In a holistic view, our agentic AI,
it could be handled like intelligent,
this is our smart
intelligent bill analyzer
where it can answer multiple
prompts or multiple requests
that we just ask the agentic
AI, then it could give us a,
you know, AI driven insights
with the proper reasoning.
Let's say suppose, how
can I reduce my bill?
Then it can advise some, okay,
we switch over to this plan, smart plans,
so that you can reduce this much
of amount every month and how can I...
and also it can compare the usage
with a similar household
items with nearest locations.
And if any disputes there,
it could answer that,
okay, how can this could be raised
and also it can break down the bill
and if a customer asks,
"Just break down my bill",
then it can segregate and you know,
show it to the customers as well.
We're not open.
- Yeah, let's summarize.
- And there are other use cases
that I'd like Laxman to
talk about the rate case,
regulatory rate case submission.
- I'll summarize.
- Thank you, yeah.
- I know we have two
minutes time coming up.
We'll just quickly,
how many of you are
utility customers here?
How many of you are utility customers?
So you can imagine, you know,
rate case is very important
for us as utility.
So what we are trying to do is,
we want to come up with
some use cases where,
how do we get all the
data in such a way that,
you know, all the utilities,
PUCs request, you know,
whether it is invoices,
whether it is bills,
everything that needs to be asked.
We are working through AI use case
connecting all our SAP, Oracle, systems
and trying to give work order number.
Then all the relevant
information related to that
in terms of that is required
to submit to our public union commissions.
So again, this is something very important
for us as a utility.
We will talk more in our next,
in our upcoming sessions
when we have, you know,
successfully completed
everything end to end.
But this is something we want to be,
you know, developing it
and we want to be one
of the leading utility
to be on part of it.
- Thank you, Laxman.
So just in a summary,
we started with the challenges today
that we see in adoption of agentic AI.
The forecast of the failure rates
and what IBM is doing to make sure
we are keeping our
clients to be successful.
Watch out this space.
Southwest Gas is highly innovative.
They move with velocity and the partners
like AWS and and ourselves and SAP,
we are working towards
making them more successful.
They have the vision, we
have do the execution.
I'm sure when you switch
on your heat tonight,
think about this case study,
think about Southwest Gas.
Thank you.
We'll be around for answer more questions.
- Thank you.